[Music]
salty sweet chewy crunchy
if the delicious combination born from
one in black America's most
consequential cultural movements it was
the 1930s the place was New York City it
was the epicenter of black Americans
movement in the mainstream culture the
Harlem Renaissance artists writers and
thinkers gather at venues in Harlem into
the wee hours of the morning listening
to touring big bands and jazz artists as
the club stayed open later and later so
did local restaurants have taken the
hungry concert goers one such restaurant
owner is Joseph T well founder of well
supper club Wells became known for its
southern inspired menu but Wells needed
a hit to stay on top of the 2 a.m.
restaurant business what could he do
seeing an opportunity Wells realized
that the fried chicken leftovers from
dinner could be served with its freshly
prepared waffles for breakfast creating
a sweet and savory concoction unlike
anything else the dish was a hit
eventually word got out and chicken and
waffles become a sole food staple from
Atlanta to Los Angeles and though Wells
closed in 1982 the dish lives on so when
you think of the Harlem Renaissance take
Duke Ellington jazz legs and huge poetry
and Joseph T Wells chicken and waffles
[Music]